hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay it looks like
we cleared up everything in the East
area or the West area that is the cycle
West yet that was the West area so we
got to go to the east area which doesn't
look as good hello
chem lab report no doubt you're aware of
the organic growth no crap sorry
no [ __ ] I've been examining the
substance aught the result would
interest you
cells close to resemble bacteria like
viral but with viral behavior like
bacteria the organism infects other
cells through osmosis then mutates and
reproduce a gamma jennacalee a Gamow
genetically sorry what's amazing is the
speed at which it grows a single
bacterium reproduces 20-fold in just one
minute I've never seen anything like it
I don't stake my reputation on it but I
think there's maybe a genuine alien
life-form preferred hallways dear
professor holy theorizes that is two
habitats transformer the levels of
gaseous output are tremendous which is
why it smells so bad but to what end we
simply don't know how about to cover the
entire ship you dumb butt oh oh oh
where's my fire stick Oh give me a fire
stick I don't have a fire
oh what are you you can shoot me a fat
I kept calm for the shock
don't throw back don't throw back
God that took like a hundred bullets
guys well I wish I I wish I had one that
was fired they were they were sitting
around everywhere those exploding
barrels and they don't give me one for
this fight they got away from you
wasteful it's okay where we're going
what am i doing what am i doing yeah
yeah out of here
no locks not locked why you didn't
bother putting in there locked do you
ever you ever ever
okay power lock give me something good I
said give me something good hmm any
monsters in here no five thousand I'll
take that ammo ammo big ol med kit and a
box oh yeah lots of goodies no schematic
though which is what I'm looking for I'm
looking for another level of my seat I'm
hoping I don't miss it
I don't know I don't even know if you
can miss it it probably in such an
obvious place cuz that's a pretty
important upgrade
who'd done here oh oh want some
vegetative anomalies detected in the
East Room chamber no kidding thank you
miss obvious computer person ah yeah
this one doesn't look nearly as video
this looks bad
yep now looks pretty bad
I'll get ready for an onslaught of
enemies yeah thank you for quarantine II
mean gonna quarantine this before
Aloha to picket nope no cases all right
look at that nope no misty wild smile
oh you must
arm and your other arm oh poor baby
yeah give me a power now get down there
those guys ain't nothin ain't nothin
well hello oh hello whoa hello
I think there's flatting everywhere oh I
get it I get it gonna feed it that's
what a grenade
damnit get it ah damn it
oh I got a space I'm an idiot again the
answer is right in front of me but I'm
far too stupid to get it I'm a big fan
dummy there we go alright that's that
and in there oh another one hiding from
me not hiding good enough especially
when my super magical beam that tracks
anything anywhere stasis thank you man
they just draw biggest row spacing
seconds it's not funny I do not need to
keep those things with me oh but I
shouldn't say that I probably do but
right now I'm cocky I don't think I need
anything my going up si what's in here
did I go in here I did not
ah what is that don't explode at me
don't try to scare me as I've said
before I'm unscareable there's another
box two boxes a I'm gonna splode on me
don't even try it
ah shut up your whispers all right where
am I going up I'm going up on the
slowest elevator I'm on a third floor
right away this one's fast laggy why is
this one so fast hmm what OH
there one up here oh I'm so smart going
straight to the pool yep
got you oh it's everywhere look at it
it's just everyone oh it's all goopy
laughs oh man oh it's just everywhere
Brody Brody Brody
all right down to level 2 I think maybe
I didn't check my guide so maybe it's
done
there's my fire stick back and something
else I didn't say oh my demonic love dr.
Krauss reporting so you were did I think
you should plan to hold her food storage
it wasn't a rogue asteroid I know what
that sounds like but it was big and
heavy I'll report again when I know more
it's a giant monster that I'm gonna kick
the ass of the bigger the monster the
bigger the ass for me to kick Oh more
goodies sitting on the ledge maybe
they're probably a lot of goodies that
are hidden away that I'm just blown
right by I probably missed hundreds of
power nodes not this yeah just just
stuff everywhere that I brought in this
cuz I haven't been paying attention and
that's that's my playstyle I don't pay
attention I ignore the easiest of
Secrets
Oh want some all this look good Gold ha
ha hey got you again Oh Oh get ready I
got super aiming oh gosh super gaming oh
my goodness that's gonna get me I'm
gonna get it yeah get it get it
shoot the damn
there we go oh man
I guess uh I guess you know if a giant
tentacle was dragging me I would
probably not be very good at aiming
either come on
all right honorable I need to help I
have a small one you say all right man
it's really nice of those monsters to
have big giant yellow glowing hit me
punks strike here this is my one
weakness hit it hard and fast huh boy
acting chief exemple I came down here to
find dr. Elizabeth cross oh yes you just
back there I can't find any running into
a gigantic monster organic [ __ ]
everywhere
I'm going to check the mining deck it's
about the only place I haven't yet it's
weird that the only survivor in here is
an engineer and the only survivor that
I'm playing is an engineer and I say
only survived because I know that this
guy is the only one that live the other
two my two allies are just gonna die
somehow I bet Hammonds dead cuz you
didn't get up out of it oh don't believe
their lies read what they're really
saying Oh an alphabet okay it's kind of
obscuring some of it there but that's
pretty cool
oh yeah all the Ollis symbols all over
the walls I guess if someone well they
probably already have anyone who's
dedicated in this game is probably
already translated
whoa it's gloopy gloppy everywhere let's
move forward because this looks safe
oh I don't look good
um
priceless yep Oh bingo
thing upgrade that duration Demyan
through G ah-ah-ah no thank you now sing
your presence really is helpful
ah no ow really is helpful for me
killing you if you announce your
president presence by screaming yeah
hello
oh god please navigate me through this
horrible maze that way oh oh I hear one
whoa I meant to navigate there
okay yes through there no not that I
really don't know what the old fire on
that one is guy here baby
I thought I heard a baby yes I heard a
baby
uh-huh I think I've been reading these
reports the curl began having mass
hallucination
and well I just found my brother on a
security monitor and that's just not
possible oh boy
yep my partners are going crazy all
right I gotta cut it here thank you guys
so much for watching we appreciate every
one of my viewers and I will see you in
the next part bye-bye